hello I'm Junior middle I am 60 meter
over the ground for an interview with
lat Bible
this love story with Heights all started
with climbing I'm just a normal rock
climber but I rapidly get used to
slacklining
when you love the heights when you love
the cliff you want to get the maximum of
all the sports that use the height and
highlining is one of the best because
you are in the void just perfect
[Music]
hi everyone windy
you discover yourself you discover a lot
of strong feelings the joy you discover
the pain you of course have fear like
everybody the first moments it's how to
control the fear during our practice we
are always facing some danger at some
point by having those little dangerous
experience to build a better practice
most of the time you have the program in
your brain this is a powerful device
that you have the more you practice the
more you stay in the air the more you
stay in this environment and the the
best you can use all your skills after
that so I add one page jumping accident
and I broke my back and one harm it
makes you think about what you're doing
in your life because once you are
stopped you have time to assess what
your life is and what is your life
without your your sports and what you
love to do
[Music]
you you probably don't know what the
flying Frenchie's are doing from scratch
you see me on a high line dealing with
Heights and Wisma with we smile and you
think I'm crazy we try to do our best to
stay alive and just to have the best fun
ever
highlining as long as i have a leash you
can practice to the maximum you can push
your limits because the gear will save
your life every time
[Music]
once you go to your everyday life then
life seems much easier actually
[Music]